[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth find and do
work that they love and create amazing
relationships I'm Ramsey personality
George camel joined by my good friend Mr
Ken Coleman and we are taking your calls
at aa825
5225 if you've got a question about
money about your work about your purpose
the impact you're making out there or
you just got a conundrum and you need a
third party uh you know maybe an
unbiased party to just give you some
advice Ken Coleman's got lots of wisdom
for you if you don't know what a
conundrum is that just means you got an
issue where you feel a little stuck and
George and I uh we're going to shoot you
straight and we're going to have fun
while we do it that's the goal that's
our that's ouro that's our prise if
nothing else so let's get to the phones
Victoria kicks us off in Destin Florida
Victoria welcome to the
show hi how you doing good how are you
how can we help today I'm all right um
I'm a little nervous um I'm just calling
because uh about five months ago I had a
still
burst so sorry at 39 and a half weeks
and um yeah so my life just been a
little crazy yeah understand and on the
work side um just this past month I
recently you know just built up the
courage to go get another restaurant job
and um turns out that they're just
running it unethically and the manager
and owner are in the tip pool and
basically stealing money from
servers so I'm just kind of at a point
where like I just reach the courage to
like go work again and um I live in a
tourist destination so I was even
surprised to get this job because most
places don't hire till February before
spring breaks so um I've tried to start
a few different businesses in the past
and they just never turn out good I've
tried MLM I've tried um I've just tried
it all and I'd like to own my own
business me and my husband are saving to
buy land because I want a Market Garden
but that's not anywhere in the close
vicinity so I'm stuck in this this like
back and forth of like well I'm grieving
so it's hard to it's hard to start
anything right now but then I don't want
to work in restaurants yeah um you know
I I owned a a child care um my first
business when I was 20 I started uh
nannying for tourists um and that did
pretty well but I at this point in time
I just can't be in the child care realm
of course you know I've tried starting a
sticker business I've
tried um I've tried several different
things like and I just don't know what
to do the internet is such a big place
it's overwhelming isn't it internet side
you know I I've written a grief Journal
it's like I don't even know how to go
about like publishing that and actually
making sales cuz that's you know Dave
talked about it like writing a book and
Publishing it unless you're on your
guys's platform is not a
shortterm thing I'm in the middle of
grazing absolutely so let's let's
simplify this for a second um do you
need the income do you and your husband
need your income or is that considered
extra um
we
are we're our shovel is not very big
sure um what is he making say we bring
in uh he just started a business at the
beginning of this year um so what is the
business he does long care La care okay
is it already successful is it is there
a net profit yeah I mean he he doesn't
have yeah we started it with cash um
we've never been in debt for it um
everything's paid for we're saving for
more equipment
it's just slow sure so so the answer is
so the answer is you do need your income
it's not like you're we we need we we're
our bills and our our life is paid with
his income but there's no extra so my
money is just the extra okay so we're
going to reverse engineer this okay with
a couple rapid fire questions so what
would be the amount of money forget what
you're doing okay but let's say we're
taking restaurant business off the table
what would be the amount of money that
if I snap my fingers and you were making
that it would you would go you would be
able to breathe easier and continue the
grieving process with a lot less stress
because of the money you're bringing in
what would be that amount of
money I mean my idea if I would my idea
would be about 6,000 just for savings
our living situation
6,000 a month 6,000 a month okay so
that's a pretty are you talking about
for the two of you or just
you for
well I'm talking about just you what
would be an income I'm trying to get to
a baseline what's the number that you
would really like to make how much four
4,000 a month 4,000 a month okay great
all right so I think that's an important
number to kind of put in the Whiteboard
of your head if you will or write it
down on a piece of paper and go okay
that's what I'm looking for financially
that becomes our goal all right now
outside of the restaurant business in
that world where there's really just no
juice you don't love it it's just kind
of something you're doing it could be
difficult the hours can be crazy you're
grieving doing some work that is
connected to that thing that you would
do which is if I give you an a blank
check to write yourself for a business
you would buy a piece of land and you
would be in gardening some type of
plants and gardening am I understanding
that
correctly yes sir okay great so here's
what I'm
suggesting and I know the area that
you're in love that area it's one of the
greatest areas on the planet our family
goes down there a lot um I would be
thinking about the gardening
centers uh I would be trying to get in
that space could you get an hourly job
or even a salary job u in that space
where someone else is paying you and
you're in that space you know healthy
plants eating fruits veggies am I making
sense so far yeah we just don't really
everything here is luxury stuff we just
don't have we don't have I'd have to go
like an hour North where we would buy
land and well forget the land right now
no I'm not talking about the land can
you get a job at the Lowe's in Destin in
the gardening center that's what I'm
saying like get around the plants and
get in that space like work for you know
a very successful farmer out there who's
they're growing this stuff and selling
it I think you need to try to get in
that space because it's something that
you really enjoy and I think it's going
to advance the healing process can I get
paid to do something very similar to
what I would do for myself does that
make sense
yes that's what I think you should focus
on you need some income you need to heal
okay and so instead of trying to start a
business or even worry about that right
now now's not the time I think you're
very mature to understand that so my
encouragement is let's get out of the
restaurant game and let's go get as
close as we can to the type of work you
really would want to do for yourself get
some stability with that full-time job
close to what you want to do while you
build this thing on the side I'm going
to send you some resources hang on the
line we're going to send you Ken
Coleman's get clear assessment that's
really going to sharpen this image of
what you want to do and we're going to
send you Dr John delon's bestselling
book own your past change your future to
help you with this grieving process and
help you take the next step I'm so sorry
for what you've been through and I'm
excited for the future ahead for you
guys and this business and we're wishing
you the best Victoria thanks so much for
trusting us with this call this is the
ramsy
[Music]
show
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need y refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with Y
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lump
some payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y refi.com
[Music]
Ramsey
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Ken Coleman this
is your show America you call us with
your questions about money and work and
everything in between 8825 5225 I know a
lot of you out there you're struggling
you don't love the job you're in you got
the toxic boss the toxic environment
there's this other thing you want to do
that you've got this itch for my friend
Ken Coleman is the expert on work and
he's going to help you make a plan and
make a path to get there and of course
I'll help you with those money questions
that are on your
mind speaking of money questions I'm
really proud of you George your new book
coming out in January that's right and
uh this is really fun it's called
Breaking Free from broke and he's got a
copy of it
the actual cover actual cover you look
great and your little denim outfit there
I shouldn't say little I don't know why
I throw that in there it's little on the
cover yeah but let me tell you what this
book is not little it's got a lot of
great content in it um and this book is
a little bit different and I want people
to know this so in your words George I
got all the Talking Points we want
people to know about the special deal
I'll get to that very briefly but how's
it different than every other money book
that we've put out well this is my
personal experience and tons of research
on how the system the financial system
is designed to screw you over how it's
designed to keep us broke and how I
broke free from it and it's a it's
controversial in today's world Ken to
tell people oh yeah I don't have a
credit score yeah I don't use a credit
card oh I don't have a car payment oh I
don't have a mortgage payment people
look at you like you got seven eyes and
so I walk people through exactly why the
system is set up this way and how you
can break free from it through very
simple steps the same steps I Ed to go
from broke to millionaire that millions
of people have stood on a debt-free
stage and talk talked about you know
budgeting and how spending can be
self-control and how you can actually
save for the future and build wealth
with patience and so but it takes
getting riled up about the current state
of things which doesn't take long by the
way that's exactly right when you look
up at all the excuses we can make and
what the system is doing to us so this
is the book I wish I had when I was in
my 20s it's very practical it's going to
feel like he's reading your mail as to
what you're dealing with and how to
break free from it it's uh available
today for pre-order for only $20 and you
get $100 in free bonus items uh
including to a talk including a talk
that George does is great it's called
show me the money you get the audiobook
the ebook and an online Q&A with George
uh all of that is available at ramsy
solutions.com ramsy solutions.com store
go pre-order it today could be a great
gift for somebody uh for Christmas as
they head of the new year with maybe
some new financial goals it's called
Breaking Free from broke and uh it's a
fabulous book you got to get it thank
you for that kind endorsement Ken you
bet by the way I noticed my endorsement
didn't make it on the back of the book
so it's a little awkward we found some U
some other some other bigger names it
looks like we thought we could have
Micro or Ken who are we going to choose
I guess I see where I stand on the old
George camel totem pole of friends he
you know what you were quoted in the
book Ken to be fair is is that right yes
I didn't even know this maybe multiple
times I must have missed that you'd have
glazed over that part I glazed over that
you're too upset tell me what page
number that is I'll get to that tonight
that'll be exciting I'll FaceTime you
will be like Dad you're so cool you made
itge George my kids think you're cool
that means the world not me well you're
a bit older than me I get it a bit not
by much I know all right let's get to
the calls Jared is in Salt Lake City
let's see if we can help him out Jared
what's going
on hey guys uh I've got a question for
you we are moving from Salt Lake to
Texas in uh June July of next year 24
and uh I've just got a question about
should could we continue paying our
monthly minimum on our student loans and
efforts to try to save up for a house
purchase that we know we're going to
have to make in that June July time
frame um or should we throw everything
that we can at our student loans now and
then um see what happens in June July
for for a house and and where to live
What's the total debt amount you owe uh
we we just have it's 135,000 in in
student loan and that's the only debt
that we've currently got well that's
plenty I don't think we need any more
yes yeah okay what's your household
income uh right now it's around 120 but
in August it should double to about 240
so this is a job in Texas or you
remote uh it's a my wife's actually in
residency right now and she's gonna
residency is ending in June and then
she'll start a new job in August um at a
clinic uh being a full-time practicing
doctor and that's why the income
increase and that's why the move as well
so doubling the income I would assume is
it a similar cost of living is it going
to be cheaper in Texas slightly it will
be it will be cheaper so like um we're
currently paying 2,200 a month in rent
um and we would rent but there's just
nowhere to rent and where we're moving
hold on hold on Jared now them fighting
words right there you're telling me
there's not a single place to rent in
Texas not one there's in this town
There's not uh very many places to R let
me rephrase that Jared wants to buy a
house am I right you're just itching to
buy a house that's okay like to buy a
house okay so here you called our show
we're going to give you our advice and
it's exactly what we would do I would
not buy a house before these student
loans are paid
off I know that stinks because that
means we're going to aggressively attack
these student loans until we move and
maybe after we move and we're going to
rent for a year maybe two years cuz then
we still got to get an emergency fund in
place we still
on that George well most people pay off
all of their uh Consumer Debt in 18 to
24 months using the debt snowball method
and with your income doubling how
quickly could you pay off 135 making
240 a year at the very latest love that
wow now you're not making that 240 for a
little while and so that's going to slow
this down a little bit do you guys have
any
savings we we've currently got about 15
in savings okay so that could be a head
start on this debt payoff and uh that'll
help you knock out this debt faster help
you get back to a fully funded emergency
fund which may be 30,000 for you guys I
don't know and beyond that we start
saving up for the down payment on a
house I imagine it's going to be
expensive in that area to buy a house do
you have a ballpark number of what it
would cost to get a reasonable home
there a a small starter home would be
around 300,000 and that's what we'd like
to move into um just a relatively
updated starter home okay so here's my
question Jared if you follow George's
advice and you should how long would you
be
renting we'd be renting
for we'd probably have to do a year
lease and rent for a year that is
nothing my wife and I rented for two
years when we moved from Atlanta back to
Nashville we had three kids so we really
wanted to make sure that we were Landing
in the right place I just want to point
that out that you're going to be
debt-free and in your first home and
that is such a better Prospect than if
you do it your way I I agree with George
wholeheartedly you're not throwing money
away by the way for a year yeah yeah and
I know you might be limited in options
of where you're going to rent that's
nearby but it's only a year you guys
sound young how old are you
two uh we're 29 and we've got a
three-month old so wow it's a
three-month old it doesn't care if
you're living in a box you know so you
get there on the ground in Texas and you
get a lay of the land I I like it for a
lot of reasons not just the financial
reasons but also just getting there on
the ground you're renting you got a lot
of freedom yeah where do you guys want
to raise that child I like that what are
the school districts like you know all
of that stuff is you need to just take
your time with it so even if you were in
a good financial position renting is
still a wise move when you're moving
across the country to figure some things
out and settle in yeah and we we know we
want to be there for the Long Haul um
the the place she's working is a clinic
that we could buy out eventually um but
we don't want to plan for that we just
want to plan for what's in this next
seven months what's in this next year
rent rent rent it's right financially
and it's right emotionally to make a
decision you feel confident in if you
guys want to be there long term I would
absolutely rent for a minimum of a year
to go where do we want to plant Our
Roots and all that's going to help you
make different decisions down the line
when it comes to buying out this clinic
and you don't have debt payments
weighing you down and you got a bunch of
money in the bank and you got a
reasonable mortgage payment cuz you
waited till you had a solid down payment
all of those things are going to affect
the rest of your life and so I want you
to make decisions now that you're going
to be proud of a decade from now where
you go yep that was the right move it
delayed us 2 years but man it catapulted
us for the
future so hope that helps Jared yeah
yeah it does thank you excited for you
guys in the move and the jumping income
and you got a little baby that you're
raising this is exciting time I got a
three-month old too Ken I know how that
yeah and you look remarkably rested
today I must say so much thick makeup
all it is you look fantastic I would be
more tan if I had makeup on let's be
honest hey more of your calls coming up
8825 5225 this is the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a 100 if you run a business
with different software systems that
don't talk to each other that's why
there's netw Suite by Oracle in the
early days of Ramsey we were using
different systems for all of our
business units we needed one single
source for accurate data netsuite was
the software we used to optimize and
take us to the next level netsuite gave
us the visibility into all of our
numbers so that we could communicate
across departments and plan ahead better
and as we grew it scaled with us net
week worked for ramsy and it will make a
difference for your business too join
the more than 34,000 customers who trust
netsuite to help make them smarter
and make better decisions and level up
their operations to learn more get a
free product tour at netsuite.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
[Music]
[Applause]
Ramsey
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Ken Coleman the
number to call is
5225 we'll take your call live and if
you're uncomfortable you're nervous we
can change your name your location we
want to do whatever makes you
comfortable we just want to make sure
you get the help that you're looking for
and our phone screener Christian can
assist you with that if you make it
through if you should be so lucky our
question of the day is sponsored by
neighborly your hub for Home Services
let me ask you this when was the last
time you thought about your dryer vent
Ken uh you know I think about it two or
three times a year because it could
cause a home fire if you don't get that
cleaned out I bet you don't even know
where yours is I didn't I know the
location do you yeah oh that's more than
I I'll I'm impressed CLE I clean out the
lint every time if that's any I now do
but several years ago I had no clue and
my father-in-law said you should
probably clean that out once a year no
clue where it was here's why it's
important those clog dryer vents are the
cause of thousands of house fires every
year that's what I just said so let the
experts at dryer vent wizard clean yours
don't let Ken Coleman do it he'll do a
terrible job 100% do not want me yikes
yeah let the pros handle it visit
neighborly decom Ramsey to schedule
service today all right today's question
George comes from Nick in Wisconsin and
I just gradu graduated college with a
finance degree and got a job offer from
a real estate investment firm to be an
agent but it's only commission which
means I wouldn't see money for 6 to 12
months uh I want to know if I should
stick with this job and get a remote
part-time job or find another job I want
to work for myself but don't have the
money and don't know where to start wow
okay so we've got a little bit of a head
spinning question here we're all over
the place um let's talk about the
Commission job so you got the job offer
from real estate investment
firm and you got to you have that ramp
up time so can you adjust your
life um would a part-time
job give you enough to stay in it a b
would the part-time job distract you
from crushing it in that first 6 to 12
months to where you're building your
pipeline you're getting going these are
questions that I would ask you've got to
get the answers to these questions
George because they really determine
whether or not the part-time job is even
an option um can you financially survive
in a straight Commission job you're not
the first person I would venture to have
to do this kind of thing so then that
begs the question do you want to be in
real estate long term if the answer is
yes uh then this is an option it doesn't
have to be the only option however this
is the game Real Estate by nature is a
straight commission play so it feels
like in the back half of the question
George he's kind of going I don't know
if I should do this I want to work for
myself blah blah blah blah blah blah and
so we've got to get clear on what's that
15 20 25 year play what's that
Mountaintop professionally that I want
to scale and I know it's hard when
you're coming out of college but it is
possible that's why I created the get
clear assessment that we sell at Ramsey
Solutions it helps you go okay what is
it that I do best what is it that I
enjoy doing and then what results
results would give me tremendous
motivation and joy if I knew I was
producing a result remember all work is
is around a product or a service I'm
indirectly involved in providing the
product or the service or I'm directly
involved and so really getting to that
that's really important for this young
man so trying some things testing some
things yeah finan your eggs in this one
real estate basket yeah Finance is such
a wide space he may go you know what I
really want to be in the banking sector
or I want to be a financial analyst or
on the investment side versus real
estate investment so uh I don't think
this is a bad move but you're probably
going to have to find an evening job to
just pay the bills and if 6 months down
the road you're like this isn't it this
is not for me you got to go find
something else but uh I would also be
asking hey can you show me what the last
five guys have made in the first six
months of them starting out just very
entry level when how long till they see
a paycheck
I just got to know for my own bills and
expenses I think that's a reasonable ask
to make yeah I think that's absolutely
right and here's something else too you
know get around people um that are in
all different areas of Finance to your
point the banker the the uh the
investment advisor you know uh whatever
all the options and and just get around
at this stage in your career you're so
young get around some people multiple
different channels if you will or lanes
and just Shadow them talk to them take
them to lunch coffee and get an idea
whether or not that's something you want
to try and I'd even do that with the
real estate Pro too we go all right do I
really want to go through the next six
months and Now's the Time while you're a
young single college grad that's the
time to try out all the things and no
one's going to miss you if you're
working at night so it's okay you did
that yeah I was working a lot of nights
just side hustling just trying to get
rid of debt get a savings goal get a
down payment for a house all of those
things and uh it didn't kill me Ken I'll
tell you that much I survived to tell
the tale you did you did thanks for the
question Nick appreciate it all right
Cameron is up next on the line in
Knoxville Tennessee Cameron what's going
on hello Mr Camel Mr Coleman how are
youall doing this afternoon doing well
how can we
help it's an absolute honor to be able
to speak to the two of y'all today I've
been listening regularly to the show for
about four years so I'm trying not to
Fan girl too hard but no promises well
George George is used to it George is
used to it he's he handles it with Grace
I'm 19 and currently studying
construction science and management at
the University of Tennessee I absolutely
love it I've been working construction
for a few years now but decided that I
wanted to run a business so I started a
little construction and handyman service
here in Knoxville I recently learned how
lucrative this kind of business can be
coming from a very humble middle class
household it's really exciting for me
just to see a check with four digits on
this excitement sadly has led me to
forget my priority here um I'm a
Christian myself myself but I've
realized that recently I've been
spending my life chasing money in
business rather than
God you broke up on his Cameron speak
directly in your phone
sorry I'm sorry can you hear me a little
bit there we go yeah what was the last
thing you he you said you were chasing
money instead of your relationship with
God that's the last thing I heard yes
sir so that moves me to my question I'm
calling today not necessarily for money
Health but more so for spiritual
guidance I want to work hard and build a
good life for myself and my future
family but I also don't want to live a
life focused on my worldly desire for
wealth how in the chase for Success have
you each personally dealt with
prioritizing your relationship with
God uh I'll jump in first and just say
that I appreciate the
question but but you working in being
successful
is not mutually exclusive from having a
relationship with God like you should be
able to do both in fact I believe if
you're going to ultimately be successful
you got to understand what the success
is based in I'll give you a verse that
stuck with me my dad gave it to me when
I was probably 16 so not much younger
than you second Timothy 2:15 this is the
King James version that's the one I've
got memorized so you can look it up in a
different version it's a little old
school but it says study to show thyself
approved unto God a Workman who needeth
not to be ashamed uh that's just part of
the verse and that with me and I I
believe that Genesis chapter 2 makes it
very clear that we were created to work
and I think you know you look at
Colossians 3:23 do your work as unto the
Lord you know work itself is in fact
what God created you to do in fact I
think there's two there's two primary
purposeful roles in a human one is
relationship first and foremost whatever
the relationship situation you've got in
your life um and and the relationship
with God so with God and then with your
family that's your primary role there's
purpose in that role and I think there's
purpose in your work role whatever it is
and and so I would just encourage you
that you're not choosing between one or
the other you can absolutely go after it
to be successful financially and
vocationally but that does not in any
way cancel out you having the ability uh
to be uh successful spiritually George
yeah I think this is going to take a
reframing Cameron to go all right money
is not evil wealth is not Evil 1 Timothy
610 says the love of money is the root
of all evil and so we've got to search
in our heart and go where is this greed
and fear and pride coming from is it a
scarcity mentality cuz I didn't grow up
with money it sounds like that's a part
of it and when you realize listen I'm a
steward of this money that God's blessed
me with in this business I want to use
it wisely I'm going to give wisely I'm
going to spend wisely I'm going to save
wisely and when you do that I don't see
it as interfering with your relationship
with God in fact I think it makes the
whole thing a whole lot richer so I hope
that helps baby steps millionaire uh
book talks about this the Legacy Journey
talks about this so check those out I
think that will help you reframe some of
this our friend Rabbi Lapin book Thou
shalt Prosper also a great read on this
[Music]
topic if you're like most people your
home is your most valuable asset and
when you want to make improvements it
can feel like everything costs too much
or takes too long but something as
simple as custom window coverings from
blinds.com can completely change your
space and add value to your home we've
recommended blinds.com for over a decade
so you know you can trust them from
blinds drapes and shutters to motorized
Shades they make it easy and affordable
to upgrade your entire home and their
team is ready to help with everything
from design consultation to measuring
and installation plus there are never
any misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save up to 50% off everything
sitewide visit blinds.com today to learn
[Music]
more
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George camel
joined by Ken Coleman this hour the
number to call Isle
8825 5225 don't be shy Ken and I are
we're we're very gentle and we're going
to make sure that you get the help you
need with very little judgment that's
true I don't know if I choose the word
gentle well you're not you're not the
type to get angry and yell at a caller
yeah you'll rant about an issue that's
right but with callers I think you're
you're kind we're here to help that's it
that's it and hopefully entertain and at
times that's we're going to try to be
fun today let's see if we can do that
here with next Tammy and Chattanooga is
up next Tammy how can we help
today thank you for taking my call um
I'm hoping I can get some advice from
yall today oh you're gonna get advice
whether or not it's good or not is up to
you well in August my husband and I
jumped on the ramay train and since
August we have paid off $22,000 in
credit to the vehicle choooo awesome
that's
awesome we we now currently owe on our
house and we only owe
$150,000 on it wow um I show that by
figuring looks like we can pay this off
in two and a half to three years the
problem is we we both currently are not
investing 15% in our retirement we both
have a pension therefore we when we
start in our careers we never invested
in a pension so because we had the
pension so we never invested in the
401ks but we currently do that now but
it's only like maybe at
3% um my husband is hoping to retire in
a year and a half to two years from his
current job but he'll still work um
after he retires but he will be drawing
the pension once he
retires so my my question is would you
suggest that we go ahead and invest at
15% um or go ahead and pay our house off
first because we can pay it off in two
and a half to three
years if we don't invest and then after
we pay the house off then we can invest
a lot into our retirement and continue
and do that then I think that you're
seeing this as a black and white ARB
issue I want you to do both of these
things you should be investing 15%
whatever whatever money's left over
let's throw it at the house now to your
point that might slow this down by six
months or a year
right um possibly a year to a year and a
half okay I'm all right with that
because that money is going to compound
for you for the next 30 Years in those
investment accounts so I don't want you
to uh delay investing at the sake of
paying off the mortgage a year
early so when it comes to this pension
is this the company is forcing this out
of your
paychecks no no
um our pension we are both in public
service
okay so so we have a pension through
that the problem with pensions is that
they're out of your control and they
perform very poorly and so I don't want
you just relying on the pension you
should also be investing in that 401k up
to that
15% okay how much is being taken out
percentage wise right now for the
pension um we don't we don't have it yes
okay yes we only contribute to the 401K
but it's like 3% that we're putting in
our 401K right now I would bump that up
and uh how old are you
too 54 uh excuse me 55 okay the good
news is you also have catch-up
contributions that will up your limits
in that 401k which is great so I would
take advantage of those while you
can and that that means putting more in
there putting even more in there catch
up
yes exactly okay so what's your
household
income um bring home we is about 86,000
before taxes is like
136 awesome all right so let's do 15% of
that and make sure that that's the total
amount you're investing over the course
of the Year and that will help you guys
retire with some with some extra dignity
cuz I don't want you just relying on
this pension because again it's out of
your control and it performs poorly so
it's going to be great to have different
buckets when it comes to retirement to
be able to draw from and uh what's in
the nest egg currently do you know what
this pension will amount
to um um I'm not really I'm thinking our
bring home uh with the pension would
probably be
about
[Music]
um
2500 to 3,000 a month okay for him once
he
retires um which is not much Plus in
what I I would say
probably bring home for a month would
probably be between three and 4,000 okay
so it be a little less than he's making
now what's the house worth
yes uh about 100 or 260,000
okay yeah we just don't know what the
future holds What expenses will be
health care costs are you going to want
to upgrade and house later on or
downgrade or we just don't know and so
I'd rather have you have a bigger pile
of money and if that means the house is
paid off a year later so be it you guys
are doing great proud of you okay well
um let me ask you one other thing we we
have to
IRAs um and we thought about taking from
them and putting that down on the house
no um boo let that grow let and in fact
if you look at our investing strategy
it's match beats Roth beats traditional
and so if you don't have a match let's
fully fund a Roth IRA for the year and
then go back to that 401k and finish out
the 15% there and that's going to help
uh again add more buckets and the Roth
IRA is great because you have unlimited
investing options and it's totally in
your control which is way better than
that pension so you guys are doing
you're doing the right things but I want
you to follow those baby steps in order
baby step four invest 15% baby step six
we're paying off the home early once we
pay off the house early then the world
is our oyster we can increase investing
far beyond that and you guys are on
track to do that in just a few years way
to go all right let's take a quick one
here from Emily in Philadelphia Emily
welcome to the show Hi how are you good
what's going on um so I just have a
question about a family business I have
worked for um my dad for as long as I
can remember um but this past year the
business is really bad um he already
sold off half of it um the previous year
and now this year business was bad again
so we ended up closing for the season um
we're usually just pretty busy in the
summer
um so right now I'm out of work but I am
staying home with my two kids uh they're
two and um well almost three and one um
so I'm trying to decide if I should go
back to work or if I should just kind of
like see what happens with the business
um or if I should just go find another
job I'm not I'm just trying to like
figure out what where I should go next
what's the number one priority with this
and what I mean by that is um do you
need to go back to work in other words
if the season comes back around and you
don't have a job is that going to affect
you guys tremendously or could you make
it without it and is that your priority
to stay home with the
kids um I love what I do and I love
working outside the home um right now
we're on baby set three and we should be
done baby set 3 by March so our main
goal is just like throw everything at
like what we can to save up um we do
expect to have another child at some
point fairly soon so and I probably I
don't know I don't think I have to go
back to work but it would definitely
help with our I would work based on what
you just told me George that's my quick
opinion on that based on what you said I
think the answer is I would work I
wouldn't wait yeah are things going to
be tight if you decided to stay home
today what does that budget look like so
right now we have about like $2,000 that
we're just like throwing into savings so
my husband brings home around like
880,000 so like we're okay but like
extra money would always be helpful I
would go into every dollar and make a
fake budget and pretend like his is the
only income and let's add that other kid
in as a line item in the budget the
diapers the expenses and see what that
would do um you know monthly for you
guys if that's going to feel tight if
you can't then invest 15% of that income
into retirement and you can't put
anything away for college and you can't
put anything toward the house then that
tells me things are too tight and we
either need to find a way for him to
make more money or for you to work
part-time in order to close that
Gap okay ises that help yeah that helps
um I haven't ever done another job other
than what I've been doing since I was a
kid so I don't really know yes but you
do have you do have some skills that are
transferable and experience that's
transferable so think about how the
skills and experience from what you have
done can be translated hang on the line
let's get her the get clear career
assessment which will help as well
thanks so much for the call Emily that
puts this hour of the ramsy show in the
books my thanks to Ken Coleman my
co-host all the folks in the booth and
you America will be back before you know
it
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm George camel here with
my co-host Mr Ken Coleman best-selling
author and host of the Ken Coleman show
and we're here for you America taking
your calls on money and work and
everything in between at
5225 Rebecca is going to kick us off in
Pensacola Rebecca welcome to the Ramsey
Show hi thank you for taking my call
sure how can Ken and I
help um I am fortunate to have a parent
who wishes to help me out a little bit
I'm in a tough situation right now with
my vehicle
and I have a parent who says I just
found out that she has a bond that she
had purchased years ago with me and mind
and
is offering to cash that
Bond and so I can get a vehicle um a
safer vehicle a better vehicle
and while I'm very glad of that there
are going to be strings attached and I'm
wondering if there are points that I
might be able to diplomatically make
with her to convince her that I am
mature enough to find you know shop and
find a vehicle on my own without it
being relegated to my brother who is in
a you know a thousand miles away she and
my brother live a thousand miles away
there's an interesting family Dynamic
the Str
the strings attached are the money is
only for a vehicle only if they buy it
and I know how I drive and the things
that I like to do and I would like to
have some agency in picking it and on
the outside chance that I can find
something nicer you you know nice enough
for less than the full amount of the
bond perhaps I could put some of that
money away for maintenance or for a a
little savings um
and You' told them this you told your
mother
this I have I just found out about it so
no I just asked if it had to be a
vehicle if they had to pick it and she
said yes yeah that part's confusing it
sounds like she doesn't trust
you no she's she's controlling it's
always been like that and I while I am
very grateful for the potential gift how
much are we talking
here possibly up to
$10,000 okay and are you in debt
currently what's your financial
situation I'm not in debt however I am
an unemployed and I'm living off my
savings I am you know I'm I'm worried
and struggling and trying to get a job
and you know I don't know what the
future is going to hold for me just like
everybody else but I'm really I'm not in
a good financial position I saved and
worked my butt off and put money away
and I've been living off savings but are
the strings attached over like let's
let's just say they just gifted you a
car you had no idea about it it was not
the car you would have chosen but it's a
free car and you're going to take
it how would you feel about that okay
you know what I get the point I would
just be like hey a free car it's amazing
it's not my dream car but I'm gonna now
here's the thing what if you saved up
and you were like you know what I'm
going to upgrade I'm going to sell this
car and upgrade to the car I really want
down the line with would they then be
upset it's possible I don't know cuz
that's the part that worries me is that
we're not done there's more strings
attached to this string that's the part
that scares me where I'd go you know
what thanks for the offer very kind of
you I'm going to handle this one I'm
going to get a job and just save up and
get upgrade over time and get the cars
that I
want but otherwise I'm taking the free
car but it sounds like there's more to
the story that you you're not going to
share in this call I I don't I want to a
little bit more can I cuz I think George
is on to it he's got he had great Spidey
spy senses were tingling yeah I but he
when he asked you would there be strings
attached if you upgraded meaning you
sold this car they gave you and down the
line and you said um probably but I'm
not sure it doesn't feel like there
would be a whole lot of blowback that
wouldn't be your answer if you thought
it was going to be like a big deal am I
right um You may be right the the
actually I think part of my hesitation
in answering was simply because wow I
hadn't even thought of it until you
started leading up to that that hey take
it and you can and I was processing what
you were leading to I was thinking well
why couldn't I just do that we've just
seen it all on this show and no one
thinks through all the different angles
and what's going to happen three years
from now and all the relational issues
that could pop up and so I'm just
thinking ahead going but what if I love
your scenario George so Rebecca what if
you did what George said and you do and
and and now this is an upgrade
responsibly is there any scenario by
which your mother would get upset over
that I don't think so I I'm just like I
I hate to see I I guess there's a trust
issue I don't trust them to to get a
good car he isn't known for that he has
my brother has like lots of junkie cars
that he's going to buy and piix up and
turn over and all that and I'm like wow
I hate to see all of that that money
just blown on oh this looks good let's
get her this isn't it your call is it
your call though no I missed that I
think it's gonna be up to him
oh he's he's a thousand they're a
thousand miles away in a Rust Belt state
I'm in sunny Florida where I can get a
car isn't a rust car I got I gotta bring
George back in here knowing what we know
I'm I either missed that but with if the
brother's buying the car and he's got a
track record of buying garbage
and she doesn't get to buy the car that
makes me nervous yeah cuz then it's
going to be her problem that she's
driving around and then paying for
repairs and maintenance I wouldn't do it
if it were me I would not take car I say
you can we can have parameters on hey
I'm going to get this car inspected
here's the amount I'm going to spend I'm
not going to spend it frivolously on
other things but outside of that this is
my decision answer George do you think
the brother would allow you to do that
the car he picks he's got to take it to
why this is his business he's clearly
not a car expert well cuz he's the
designated uh mom has designated brother
as the expert is that what I'm
guessing I think so and he they there's
a very there's a very um codependent
relationship between it's almost like
they're an unhealthy marriage it's
mother and son so it's like they're both
very very controlling including trying
to control me which you know we're all
much past the age of that um this whole
thing just feels weird over 10 grand I
just I would tread very lightly and
because I think there's more where this
came from down the line and he's going
to be talking to Mom about what you did
with that car and it's going to just
cause more relational drama down the
line so you just got to be prepared for
that if you choose to do this I'm out
yeah I'm out what about taxes Rebecca
I'm out if I were you I wouldn't do this
this stinks well you'll pay sales tax on
the vehicle yeah and if you're
registering in Florida it would be the
Florida sales tax on vehicles that's
right so you'd have to factor that in
the equation
I'm so sorry yeah would there be a tax
just on her cashing this Bond would
there be a tax to me if it says p o d in
my name because I'm not I don't think
that I'm actually on the bond I saw it
and I saw a picture of it and it's in
her name with her social security number
only it's my name and social security
number my social security number is not
on the bond but it just says at the
bottom p o d it gives Rebecca's name if
she's the owner of that would count as
income on her and so I would look into
that as well because that could count as
taxable income for you it's not going to
be a deal breaker but it's something to
think about as you uh file taxes I'm out
we're
[Music]
[Applause]
out hey guys it's Rachel Cruz it's open
enrollment season so it's a great time
to explore your health care options for
next year if you feel tied down by your
budget check out Christian Healthcare
Ministries chm is not health insurance
it's a faith-based health cost sharing
Ministry that has helped members take
care of nearly billion doar in
healthcare costs chm is an affordable
alternative to insurance that gives you
the freedom and empowers you to live out
your values and you can join at any time
so find out more at chministries.org
budget
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Ken Coleman
you've probably heard us talk about
every every dollar it's our worldclass
budgeting app that helps you manage
money the ramsy way and it simply Works
wherever you are iOS Android or online
and you can start every dollar for free
and immediately see where you stand with
money it's like a mirror for your
finances it's going to help you get
organized personalize your budget it's
going to help you stop overspending and
save more money and if you're new to
every dollar we'll show you a long-term
Financial road map which helps you track
your net worth your debt free date your
retirement date your baby step progress
and more so go download the free every
dooll app for IOS and Android or go to
everydollar.com and get started Adam
joins us up next in Omaha Adam welcome
to the
show hey thank you guys so much for
having me on the show I really
appreciate it absolutely what's going on
with
you so get to the point uh about three
weeks ago uh my job was dissolved I put
that in quotes because uh I was laid off
and that's what they told me was was the
reason and so I'm out been I listen to
your show every day I've been listening
to you guys for Years first time caller
and I've applied for lots of jobs gotten
call backs and now I've been getting I
got an offer in but it's lower than I
was making and so my question is does it
behoove you to take a lower paying job
while you're still looking
or would it be better to either like
maybe get on unemployment or just use
your what emergency savings you do have
to uh while you're looking for a job to
get some more money in my life currently
does work so yeah I think it depends on
your financial situation is the answer
to that question do you guys have the
ability to live off can you live off of
her income for a few more months if
that's what it
took it would be pretty tight we'd
probably have to sell some stuff um we
maybe set two and we've gone we went
from da from uh ish to full bow
loan so we've gotten rid of all of our
extra money and put it into all the
bills that we had how much less we do
have this how much less money would you
be making if you take this current offer
than what you were making how much money
less over 20,000 okay less so the
question then becomes uh could you make
that amount of money with a couple of
part-time
gigs uh and and not take this full-time
gig that's one question the other
question is is if you take this
full-time gig that's paying you less
things aren't going to be
tight um but would it look bad if you
were to move on two or three months
later is it in the same field is there a
negative for you taking this current off
and and then moving on maybe a few
months
later no and that's something that my
wife had brought up was is to take it's
it's outside my normal field I'm retired
it the military and it's going to be
it'll be working with veterans helping
them helping veterans but it's not in
the it field I do it so it could be
something I absolutely love for I would
do it I would do it it's here's why it's
going to stabilize you financially and
emotionally it sucks point it really
sucks to lose a job I don't care what
they say it's dissolved or whatever we
know from psychology research that
losing a job has the same emotional
impact as losing a loved one it
sucks and yeah getting a job where
you're working with veterans even though
it's not in your field of training I I
would guess that's going to help with
your
healing um there there's there's these
are these are brothers and sisters in
arms if you will you've got a connection
there I think it's going to stabilize
you just by getting back out and working
again not not being at home and think
it's going to help the healing process
that's what I mean by stabilize you
emotionally and we know it's going to
stabilize you financially because even
though it's a little bit of a hit and I
mean 20,000 is over 20,000 is a
significant hit I don't want to minimize
that by saying a little the point is is
that it's not going to hurt you guys
aren't going to be hurting you're not
going to be as tight and I think it sets
you up and then and then when you get
back into it because I believe you
will um you're not going to look like a
flake at all you're like look I went and
help veterans while I was looking for
another it job I I think it's a great
move George yeah I'm with that I would
take this lower paying job especially if
you've got to make this decision soon if
you don't have time to go look for that
better offer I'd rather you take this
one cuz what we've seen is people call
the show and they go well when's the
last time you're working well it's been
six months and I've just been looking
for a job I haven't found the right
perfect one yet and I'd rather you be
working in the meantime like Ken was
saying um you know adding to the resume
having that impact getting out of the
house making that money versus just
continuing to look for this needle and a
hay
stack now what if it's so yes so i' be
going from like Friday one job Monday to
the new job but one if this something
end up loving and I know that i' I've
heard Ramsey say uh he talked about well
I even heard you guys talk about if if
you can make more go to help get a
bigger shovel but when if I end up
loving this job and it's it's not the
big a shovel we can still make it and
we'll still have our margin will still
be somewhat decent to get out of debt
within the key here is to not slow down
your gazelle intensity and so if that
means picking up an extra side job on
top of that to get out of debt by your
debt free date you guys had in mind
that's fine by me that's I I agree with
George I what I would tell you is if you
love this veterans job you know what you
do you go get yourself a freelance Tech
job it because you're good at it you're
freelance I've been doing it for 25
years you're very good at it very
connected so yeah I think George is
absolutely right I just pivot and I go I
stay in the veterans job serving
veterans I love it and I'm G to make
some money in it on the side and get out
of debt and get the emergency fund
funded and I think that's a no-brainer
and then once you're out of debt and
you're in a better place fin finially
you get to make the call do I drop the
side job do I you know is this enough to
to keep our bills going and help us
accomplish our goals so thanks for the
call all right let's go to Jordan in
Irvine California Jordan welcome to the
Ramsey
Show hi thanks for having me yeah
absolutely how can we
help so wanting to know if it makes
sense to sell our current home in
California which we still have a
mortgage balance of about 650 ,000 use
that Equity that we've gotten from the
appreciation and buy a house in cash out
of state and have zero debt or does it
make sense if we try to keep the
California House rent it out and then
take out a second mortgage loan for a
new home that we'd potentially be moving
to and living in well I'll tell you
which one sounds more
stressful option b i I can probably
guess yeah double mortgage trying to be
a landlord long distance all of that is
going to uh not really give you a smooth
move and when you land you're not going
to have as much peace as you would if
you had no payments in the world and you
got to then save up and if you wanted to
buy an investment property in your new
location you can do that because you
don't have a mortgage payment and so
that would be the time to do that but if
you said hey I want to buy two houses at
once we'd go gosh that's crazy and so
that's essentially what we're doing here
and I I
understand that we can get star eyed at
the numbers of I could rent it for
$3,000 i' more than pay for the mortgage
it sounds great on paper right but the
paper doesn't reflect reality of the
hassle that it can be to do something
like that while having two mortgages and
having to cover all the repairs
maintenance bad tenants you name it sure
and I assume even if we look to have one
of the property management companies
where they take 10% of the monthly rent
still still going to have the headache
still not worth it is that your opinion
yeah and we would there I don't think
there's been a call on the show where we
said yeah go ahead and keep it just be a
longdistance landlord in almost every
case and if we could go back in time I'd
tell you don't do investment property
until you can pay cash and your primary
home is paid off and so this helps you
sort of have a fresh start you're going
to have a home paid for in cash that's
incredible what a great way to kick off
this move that you guys are making and I
don't think you're going to look back
with a regret at the money we could have
made on the
rental sure no that that all sound and
makes sense one man's opinion Ken do you
think uh anything different here I know
Ken he loves he's like don't sell it
don't sell it yeah I I don't disagree
with you I think you're absolutely spot
on here I've just seen too many where
people said we kept it as a rental we
thought it was going to work out and I
thought your metaphor was strong where
you just said we'd never tell you to buy
two houses and I think funny it's the
same thing I thought what do I add to
that like magnopus it was you dropped it
and I went okay I just wanted to make
sure you you look pensive over there
like oh boy I was thinking through it I
think thinking through the motivations
behind all of it patience is what I was
thinking but I think the financial
advice is great I would I would agree
with you 100% wealth is patience I'm
more of a tortoise Ken and some people
find that advice controversial these
days you know what tortoises aren't
financially risky that's true they're
steady but they make it they always make
it eventually you look like a tortoise
in that shirt by the way I don't know if
that's a compliment but I'll take it
this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
[Applause]
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a
$5,000 seller guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being accepted the
home buyer Edge from Church Hill gives
you an advantage over those other guys
go to Churchill mortgage.com today to
learn
[Music]
more
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campell joined by my friend Ken
Coleman and we're taking your calls at
5225 it's a free call and uh you can
make it if you so choose if you can get
through to our friend Christian screen
in the phone calls he would happily let
you through and we can try to help help
with whatever situation you've got going
on Mike is in Phoenix up next Mike
welcome to the
show hello how you doing doing pretty
well how are you I'm doing good thanks
for uh taking the call um like listening
to you guys and uh um surprised I got a
call in or you know was able to get
accepted so that's cool welcome um yeah
thank you so uh throughout my life um
been a pretty good saver uh followed
Dave Ramsey's uh path and was at baby
step 4 um but currently uh it's not
looking good um purchased a house last
year and it found out that it's filled
with mold
um and uh it's it's pretty bad um as far
as
options um so right now my family we're
looking at uh possibly having to walk
away from the home um just because kind
of ran out of
options and just you know I like I love
listening to you guys all the time so I
just figured you know what um maybe they
might have some advice um on maybe some
next steps to take what are your current
walkway options what what does that look
like short sell H um just because you
know foreclosure would be an option to
but short sell um is definitely option
from how much damage is it what what
what is the are you getting quotes on
what it would take to remediate or fix
it that's correct yes it's pretty
extensive uh it is i' be so underneath
you know upside down in the house if I
were to do the repairs is it everywhere
tell me paint the picture yeah um it is
everywhere um there we do suspect that
there was fraudulent activities going on
um in the home prior um they it was you
know it was hidden pretty good um not
pretty good actually hidden really well
and you've got a professional mold
inspection already done correct and a a
hygienist and you know I did all the
proper precautions uh pre um purchasing
the home and the home inspector found a
minor spot you know in in an area that
wasn't even um in that General vicinity
so you know that's kind of you know
sometimes you'll find that with
purchases so you know you figured all
right you know that's not you know we
could we could deal with that but then
after um moving in the house within just
a few weeks and things started to show
up you know that weren't in the area of
concern and um just
started getting real concern so that at
that point you know had a mold um
remediation company come out and do an
invasive inspection just because home
inspections are non-invasive yeah as I
learned you know um so this you're
telling me though the seller knowingly
concealed this mold problem and provided
false
information that's what we're suspecting
if that's the case I would be going to a
real estate attorney I think you've got
you could have a case here what did they
say we've already got I've gone down
that path um and then the other thing is
just my concerns like I I want to to
speak with you guys for in regards to
way you know more information I've just
been kind of nervous just because there
is a a process that um I have gone you
know down some of the routes that you
just discussed so that's one of the
things you know that you know I don't
want to say the wrong thing or you know
what I mean and that and that kind sure
I I mean I don't think you have any
recourse here except legal
recourse right I'd rather you fight this
thing and I in the meantime you're going
to have to find a different living
situation I wouldn't be living in that
house with my
family right yeah but I would be looking
at all the options and seeing your legal
rights are going to be the big piece of
this equation to see if they'll you know
compensate to basically gut this home
and do the mold
remediation right
and yeah just for for buyers you know I
really am I'm like I'm a nervous buyer
now like I would buying the next home is
going to is so nerve-wracking oh yeah
you got some trauma now well but let me
say this I ran into a situation uh with
our current home uh and and and it was a
crazy situation we were just doing some
basic Remodeling and found a wall with a
good amount of mold on it and it was
coming from an area uh off of the roof
that had not been flashed properly and
so once we figured it out where it was
coming from then we were able to address
the situation and it costs a lot of
money I mean it nowhere near what you're
dealing with but speaking to you moving
forward I mean a really good inspector
and you're checking for it mold comes
from water so where was the water coming
from and and you've got some experience
now so oh yeah and it's from fraudulent
activities too that's we suspect that
it's not a natural experience that homes
go through what does that mean my
drift what are they spraying the walls
on purpose I don't understand what that
means so as far as what we what we
suspect is you know
uh
growing okay so they have so they have
uh it's not a greenhouse but they were
treating it like a greenhouse and extra
moisture to grow illegal okay there you
go that's a worse that's
all right then so my friend let's focus
on the future here that's all right
that's I need the I need the future like
my future self let me tell you something
you have all the evidence in the world
from these remediation companies that
there is mold all over the place that
was I would you absolutely have got a
you find the right lawyer who sees the
basic evidence as we've heard it and
they get rewarded when you get rewarded
I would absolutely get a bulldog on this
and fight it I need yeah all right what
I've been learning it's not pro bono too
that's the other thing nobody said pro
bono do you have money to pay for a
lawyer personal injury lawyers get paid
on the back end of situations and so I'm
guarantee you can fight a lawyer who
goes we got something here and I'm and
I'm I'm going to I'm going to take these
clowns to the bank and and I'll get paid
nicely yeah you you sound like a wounded
wounded dog and I get it oh yeah but
listen but Mike you you gotta fight for
this I do
I defitely you don't have any other
option don't take it laying down you got
you were you were a victim here go find
a lawyer who sees it is going to go to
the go to the mat for
you yeah definitely so what's the total
mold remediation
cost oh that's Hefty it we're looking at
about three over three that's just
remediation that's not rebuild over
$300,000
yeah yeah
that's uh we're not going to do that
what's the house worth I don't know if I
believe that
1.1 it's worth 1.1 it's a big big place
yeah and it's totally covered in mold
they found it every in every wall
infested oh gosh so basically rebuilding
this house from scratch it sounds like
like bulldozer time golly yeah I would
fight this this is big enough that it's
not a it's a stupid tax we're just going
to pay it there's no way who are the do
you know the pre do you know the
previous
owners unfortunately yeah are what are
they reputable people like out there in
the community and this was a side thing
huh yeah I would yeah probably not
they're not probably not I
wouldn't yeah yeah you know what I mean
well but I mean that's my point is if we
pursue suing them like can they even
come up with it exactly that's what I'm
dealing with too that what I've heard is
that you I put a lean on you know their
home and as you guys know uh being well
versed in finances and mortgages and
homes and what and such the mortgage
company gets first so um they're getting
paid before you do man that is it you
Mike Mike Mike I'm so sorry you're going
through this man this is just a bummer
all around I we are not lawyers but I
hope you find a bulldog and you fight
this thing and you call us back with
some good news man we are wishing the
best for you in this mold situation this
is the Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
Show
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Ken Coleman we
got a lot of fun stuff happen happening
in the ramsy solutions store including a
new book from Jade warshot a quick read
called money's not a math problem it
comes out December 5th and you can
pre-order today for just 10 bucks and
you'll also get access to a live online
Q&A with Jade on top of that our friend
Rachel Cruz has released a wonderful
kids book that is beautifully
Illustrated it's called I'm glad for
what I have that's also available for
pre-order now and uh the other things
you can get on there is the new goal
planner for 2024 featuring some of our
Ramsey personality friends and of course
we've got the Cyber Monday sale being
extended because uh we want to make sure
you guys can get all your shopping done
and we've got our best deals of the Year
happening at ramsy solutions.com store
you'll also find my new book Breaking
Free from broke on there uh questions
for humans conversation cards there's
just something for everyone and so go
check it out and uh stock up for the
year I know a lot of you love to give
out The Total Money Makeover as gifts I
do that like the you know I had a pest
control guy over we start talking about
finances and I just I always have them
on hand to go hey here's this book
changed my life I hope it helps hey uh
you know Shameless plug here don't
forget your co-host you know you're
starting out the new year you're
thinking about hey I want to do work I
finally want to pursue this work that I
love I want to Chase the Dream from
paycheck to purpose to get clear career
assessment don't forget those products
and many of the audio books are on sale
for as low as five bucks so if you
prefer listen to $5 as low as man I'm
not making any money on that Dave what's
he doing he listen I don't call the
shots Ken I just report the facts that's
fact so ramsy solutions.com
store is the place to go Max is up next
in Chicago Illinois Max welcome to the
Ramsey
Show good afternoon George K how are you
guys doing well good how are
you H not too bad what's going on uh so
my question is um and I I called in
about three years ago and Dave just kind
of hammered me and I never really got an
answer my question but that happens in a
similar situation so okay uh basically
how do you handle financing uh the
retention of a lawyer and obviously
ongoing fees as you uh go through you
know what whatever it was originally was
a divorce now I'm going through uh you
know fighting over my kids um so just
how do you maintain that I mean I I just
blew through my what I had saved as my
emergency fund um on the first lawyer
and it's like now you're back to zero
again and uh it's like where do you go
from there I mean they obviously wanted
it immediately so how much have you
spent so far in legal
fees so the divorce cost me 60 so I I
paid that off back to back to no debt um
no credit cards and and that's how I got
through that one was I ended up getting
two credit cards paid them all off got
back to zero had eight grand saved um
heading towards my you know 25 uh about
20 grand in emergency run that I needed
and that immediately was gone so I I
I've just dropped about another 11 uh
going into the second lawyer now since
June and is is this custody battle soon
to be over what's the timeline look like
I mean is it just never ending there's
not there's not and that's the the I
guess issue with the system is is they
tell you that it's over but then anybody
can go back to court and you know file
fees or whatever and paperwork and then
it just obviously just compounds uh time
over time um I mean the divorce is bad
enough but when you're fighting over
your kids it's completely different you
know so now how how is your your ex
partner dealing with all the legal fees
cuz this seems never ending are they
just trying to get you to where you give
up because of the
fees yeah and basically her I think hers
are just being paid for by somebody else
so I don't think it's an issue for her
so um obviously it's an issue for me so
what are the ongoing legal fees per
month so initial my first retainer um
was 7500 which like I said about wiped
out what I had saved um and then
obviously you know working through that
that's he's higher than normal but um
became highly recommended had him since
June uh just really wasn't doing much
for me so went through that just hired
another one um and this guy was $3,500
retainer and then basically once you get
through that you're getting hit with a
3500 every time you go through it so um
so we're talking 3500 a
month and it depends I mean like the
7500 lasted um five so okay again
depends what you're doing how many times
you're going to court how much paperwork
how you know how much contact you have
with your lawyer every phone call every
email um I'm just trying to find an
average here so we can figure out how
much you need every month in order to
cover this and how long you can go for
at this
point and and that's I guess the hardest
thing is you don't know because you know
when I looked at that when I looked back
at the divorce there's no way to track
it because some months it was like very
little um and then other month is you're
getting you know things sent in from the
other side and then you have having to
respond to them and documentation and
putting things together and meeting with
your lawyer uh then the next month is
you know you've doubled what you spent
the first month so it just it's almost
impossible to track well is there an end
in sight is there like a court date
where we got the judge and I'm you know
is there some end in sight on this as to
when this gets
resolved I mean at this point it's gone
on six months we just extended it into
almost January um and that's that's the
other part of it is I think the lawyers
need to have come to meeting and go guys
we got to come to a resolution
here why and obviously the downside is
that they that she just wants me to give
up right and it's my kid so or just find
some compromise it may not be hey one
person got it all and you know what's
the custody right
now so we settled after the divorce was
settled at 5545 okay and no child
support she made more than I did no
issue um so you know lead three years
forward I'm making more than she is and
she wants full custody and child support
so basically I would not see my kids at
all no listen neither one of us are
saying you don't fight for your kids I'm
not saying that what I am saying is this
kicking the can down the road I think
you've got some good Instinct on this is
she's trying to bleed you out and so we
stop that so we fight that we go no
we're not doing this we're not kicking
it to January what why do we need to why
do we need to push it to
January you know it's this is the deal
this is what the previous settlement is
I would be saying to your lawyer to her
lawyer like we're not doing this let's
get in front of a judge the judge
decides anyway we have been three times
that's part of the issue is that they
just okay we're going to follow up and
hey it can't be 20 days later it's a
month and a half later and you know this
is when they got time and so the next
hearing so I yeah trust me so the next
hearing is in
January yeah that they'll be one that
that I want need to go to is in December
but it'll end up in
January well
here's I I I don't want to get down this
rabbit hole but I think you got to fight
and I think George is right you know you
you got to go I have at least a ballpark
and I think you tell your lawyer look
this is what I can do this is realistic
I don't need to you know we don't have
to respond to everything if the next
thing in front of the judge is then then
that's what we do like at some point
You' got to take control of this as to
much as much as you can
and financially you got to go work yeah
you might need to go get an an extra job
just to cover these fees but do not go
into debt uh especially compounding
month over month to try to resolve this
for the next year that's not a
solution so how much do you
make uh it'll be about about 120 this
year okay so I would just Factor this
into the budget take the average of what
you've been paying maybe you just divide
it out over the how many months you've
had a lawyer and go all right I really
need need to be budgeting about 1,500
that might mean I need to cut expenses
that might mean I need to go get an
extra job in order to cover this through
January but be honest with your lawyer
and say that's it after January I'm
tapped out man we got to come to a
resolution here and I know that that's
it's easy to say from the desk but we
also can't just kick this another six
months because you're going to be 60
Grand in debt trying to pay this off for
the next three
years again yeah I I follow you so I
wish we had a better answer m it stinks
there's not really a you know a
beautiful magic scenario we can just lay
out here that solves all of this this is
just messy and this is what it looks
like when you know marriage becomes a
business transaction and things get you
know what irritates me
George the
lawyers they ought to go before the
judge and go hey judge we know you're
the final say on this what do you need
from us this gentle this gentleman can't
keep doing this we don't like it's some
point the judge has got to have some
stinking common sense and go I'm not
going to break somebody financially over
a custody battle doesn't seem like this
is hairy enough to Warrant all this
garbage no sir come on where's our
common decent I'm just glad I'm not a
lawyer Ken I think we're in the right
field although you would have made a
great lawyer and another life it's not
too late Ken it's not too late things
don't go well for you here you're still
time hey that puts this hour of the
Ramsey Show in the books I'm George
camel he's Ken Coleman we'll be
[Music]
back
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm Ramsey personality
George camel joined by the one and only
Ken Coleman and we're taking your calls
at
8825 5225 live you call us up we will
give you our best wisdom on your
situation regarding work and money Megan
kicks us off in Kansas City Megan
welcome to the
show Megan are you with us hey yes there
she
is what's going
on um so my husband um spends on average
about $1,000 a month um at gas stations
um um for you know snacks drinks um a
majority of that though is for chewing
tobacco and my question um is how can I
help him
become how can I help him work towards
becoming more financially responsible um
so that we're not worrying you know how
we're going to make it till the end of
the month with bills and other
priorities how long has this been going
on
for um
it's been going on for a few years um it
has gotten worse though within the last
year or so is he using more chewing
tobacco what do you think the pro the
problem is there um definitely more
chewing tobacco um he goes through maybe
two to three cans a day and that can be
pretty pricey um and it's it hurts us
financially um as you could probably
imagine I assume you've had
conversations with him about this how do
those go yes um they they don't go very
well it usually starts an argument um he
uh he has tried to quit multiple times
through the last several years um we've
done medical we' we've we've spoken to
doctors um he's put been put on
prescriptions he's tried the patches
everything um he's tried quit quitting
cold turkey and just nothing has worked
and um especially since we now have a
family I really thought that that would
help out in getting him to quit but it
hasn't so what why did the patches not
work if it's giv him the same unless he
just the patches can't possibly give
what three cans a day is given yeah um I
think it's just it all boils down to you
know deep down he really doesn't want to
quit no he loves he likes it yeah and I
just can't really find anything that
gives him that push to do you know if
it's is it is it relaxing to him what is
the benefit is it a buzz that chills him
out what's going on I well he does have
ADD so um I think it just chills him out
but also it's become such a habit um and
he I think it's just that yeah that buzz
maybe yeah well and I wonder if there's
not something else below the surface cuz
what doctors are trying to treat they
can't treat feels like this is something
in his soul in his heart that's what I
think is that true no I agree with you
what does he do for work agree um he is
an HVAC technician yeah does he like his
job oh yes very much so yeah this is
deeper than this this is deeper so
here's the deal
um we got to get that part figured out
or any Financial advice or any
conversational or communication advice
we give you is is largely going to fall
on deaf ears because because he's
defensive now however I do think there's
a money piece to it but I think it has
to be whatever's going on that is
requiring you to medicate yourself this
way is going to break
us that's the depth of this and and so
we've got to get to that and then the
financial piece will take care of itself
CU he doesn't have to
medicate M yes so in the meantime since
we can't solve that George I I want to
know what George thinks I I think this
is a so I'm gonna come back to this in a
sec I want to come back to the
conversation of what she might say but I
want to bring in the financial in this
case giving her advice this is such a
sensitive issue that's got a lot of
depth to
it could she get him on board with all
right you got to go get a side hustle to
the tune of ,000 a month to cover this
medication I am I
I think that's a fair ask what do you
think George yeah I mean there with
addiction it's not as simple as saying
hey we're gonna we're gonna cut him off
yeah and so I I still think I'm not a
medical professional I think cold
turkeyy is the way to go and I think it
starts with this conversation of you
going listen this is going to
deteriorate your health I want you
around to see our kids grow up I want us
to actually hit our financial goals is
derailing us financially for you to be
spending this way and by the way gas
stations are one of the worst places to
buy all of this stuff it's the highest
cost and so if he's going to do this
he's got to be smarter about it than
just impulsively stop and byy the gas
station every 4 hours and so he's got to
find a way to curb the spending even if
it's hey we're cutting back no more food
snacks drinks all this stuff yeah I I
think that's the key you have to say
babe I'm worried about this and you're
going to have to get more involved in
the finances do you guys have combined
bank
accounts no and because of that reason
yeah and I know that's something I've
struggled with um I've taken control
somewhat of his uh bank account um just
so that I can monitor his spending and
every month it's the same thing when we
sit down and have that talk like hey
you're spending way too much and it's
just yeah it's is this on a credit card
a debit card debit okay and so he's got
the money but it's his income and he's
just spending down his account every
month doing this yeah and we've even
tried with um having him send um me uh
like a certain percentage of his
paychecks that I would then put into
savings or it would go towards um bills
for that month I think you need to tell
them listen I didn't sign up to be
married to a child that I have to
monitor in
babysit you need to care about this
family more than you care about your
chewing tobacco habit and I need you to
show me that conversation yeah and if if
you guys need to go to counseling to
deal with the the marital issues this I
think if you don't it's going to cause
more resentment and this marriage isn't
going to survive this George is right
cuz this is going to just compound every
month for the next what another three
years of this well you're not going to
solve it you can't solve it he has to
understand how afraid you are how
exhausted you are how it's affecting you
guys how it's affecting your marriage
and what that's going to have an impact
on the rest of his life and then he's
going to have to get to the bottom of
what's going on with him which is
causing the medication of the tobacco
and then you got you have to fix what's
already been in some ways bruised and
broken with you two all of that has to
happen or this this spending isn't going
to stop yeah even if we go hey tell them
to get in bulk at Walmart well that
might be a Band-Aid that might save us
200 bucks a month but it doesn't solve
the real problem
here you know I agree I'm sorry you're
going through this Megan I again I wish
we had a magic answer for you I think
it's a come to Jesus meeting I really do
yes I I agree and I I know addiction is
one of the most difficult things a
person can deal with and I encourage him
to call Dr John deloney show to walk
through that piece of it and if he's
willing to call he's really serious
about this um we can get him on the line
with our friend Dr John to help him work
through that but that's the only answer
to this money problem is him overcoming
this addiction this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by my good friend
Ken Coleman the number to call is
5225 let's keep the calls rolling we're
headed to Manchester New Hampshire up
next with our friend Jean Jean what's
going
on oh not much well something going on
Jean tell us about I'll tell you what
I'll tell you what's going on Jean
before we get to your question how many
presidential candidates have you seen in
the last six months in
Manchester um you know I I'm just uh
going to stay away from all that and be
happy at home smart smart woman but
you've seen some
yes yeah yeah you get that it's first in
it's you got Iowa New Hampshire and
they're just the big one all candidates
are just everywhere in those States
so Jean she doesn't want any of it she
wants no part of it let's talk money
instead of
politics oh yeah I've been watching the
ramsy show we paid off all of our credit
cards chopped them all up paid off our
cars bought my Sonic car in cash um you
guys are doing doing good for us you did
you're doing the good work look at you
we sat back and relaxed here at the desk
we're proud of you awesome um so I in
2017 we refinanced our house in order to
purchase a commercial property for our
business
business um and our home at the time at
this time we're making four times the
monthly payment so we're paying that off
hopefully in the next couple years it
has 61,000 left on it but we're kind of
looking at like at the end of the year
we can invest in our
Ira but I mean I'm 47
so it's kind of like do I invest in the
ira or just put all that money down on
that home loan because the home loan is
at the beginning I mean it's only 6
years old
so okay and so how what is the the track
to pay this house
off um hopefully within two years
because we're making four times our
monthly house payment every month
awesome but you're not
investing um we did last year we put in
the maximum for our IRAs both of us for
last year and we were able to do it for
the prior year is that the only thing
you're doing is the
IRAs yes you should look into uh so you
guys are are you self-employed is just
you two or is there more people yes we
both we are we both are self-employed we
both go in the business and it's just
you two yep okay I would look into uh
better retirement options through your
business like a solo 401k and a SEP
IRA
and with that solo 401K it's going to
allow you to invest way more than those
IRA limits so I just want to throw two
options out there to look into you can
contact one of our smartvestor Pros on
our uh website through our smartvestor
program and they can navigate which
option is the right one for you based on
your specific business but I think
that's going to really help you guys
retire with dignity versus just the
IRA I looked into solo 401k and we have
like one employee so it's not actually
like I don't think we can do that but
anys I will look back into that
definitely to the set may be an option
still I hadn't heard that so yeah check
that out so that's that side now the
what are the other debt you have other
debts you have outside of the mortgage
we have nothing we have my house which
ow we owe 61,000 and then the commercial
property um has two loans on the
commercial property they made us split
like half SBA loan so the SBA has 74,000
but we can't pay that off until
2027 and then we have a regular oh yeah
this is a stupid move I wasn't listening
to you guys then um our
$96,000 loan for the commercial property
actually is an
adjustable rate and my dad has been
freaking out about
that okay why is your dad freaking out
what does he have to do with it oh cuz
he also listens to you guys so he's like
you should not have an adjustable rate
loan I'm like yeah well yeah that was
2017 so well I would still be investing
15% and I would be tackling I'm going to
couch this all in kind of this weird
baby step 6 real estate pay
down okay so I would be you know that
might slow you down on the house payoff
but it's also going to help you have a
bigger nest egg you know 15 20 years
from now keep doing the retirement at
the same what is the what's your
household income that you're taking home
home every year uh 72
72,000 okay and that's between the both
of you that's what you're yeah combined
that's
gross yes I would try to find a way to
make more through this
business we are okay CU that's
equivalent to you both that's each of
you making 36k which you could go
exactly do that in a retail job and so I
want this business making more money or
else we need to go find something else
to do to where we can both be making
75k right
so that's just a goal for you guys to
set as you look forward to the next year
if we can't ramp this business up and
scale it we may have to look at other
options perfect so thanks so much Jean
you guys are on track we just got to get
rid of all this debt and uh you know
we've all made money mistakes some
sometimes they have a lot of zeros on
the end and sometimes they have an
adjustable rate that sucks all right
Jake is in Salt Lake City up next Jake
what's your
question hey thanks for taking my call
you guys sure um so I I am 23 my wife is
24 and we have a family investment
opportunity in an Uncle's company and I
have me and uh two brothers and my
parents who are going in on this
investment my question is essentially
what's the safest way to pull together
money as a family that is also legal so
we could pay taxes on it the right way
and nothing will come back to bite us
what do you mean by that you're pulling
the money together so walk me through an
example of what this investment would
look like yeah my uncle has done this
before he owns six or seven
multi-million dollar companies um and
essentially he's reached out and given
every family 1% that they can buy into
this it's valued at 2.5 million right
now so each family can buy in
25,000 I I want to put in 10,000 my
parents are going to do 10 as well I
believe and then I have a brother who's
doing three and two respectively then in
5 to 10 years when the company is uh
worth more and we decide to pull out our
share we'll just redistribute
proportionately if that makes sense and
how guaranteed is this
return I mean I'm comfortable losing
10,000 I wanted to do 25 like my own per
but that's just with what I'm that's
what I'm comfortable losing it's pretty
sure though my uncle's putting all of
his kids trust funds into it he's done
this thing before and I think in past
days he had like a 50 50 times return so
it was really good this one's estimated
to be like 100 to 300 times Roi it could
be really good and with M that big
you're telling me he's going to scale
this $2.5 million company
300X he works in medical uh Plastics and
he has some outof country businesses as
well that are vertically integrated this
is like the last key piece that needs to
be vertically integrated before stuff
can like he's already blown up his
companies in the past but this is going
to make it just that much
easier my only hesitation is when
something sounds too good to be true it
is and so that's my only now the you
could be saying all the right things and
you could 300 extra money and I hope
that for you but I just walk into this
with some hesitation when it's family
and it's an investment opportunity those
words rarely end up going well for the
person who is doing the
investing yeah this is why I'm trying to
be so careful I'm fairly conservative
I'm skeptical that's all you called us
what's Your Gut
Jake you know my problem as far as you
know where I'm learning about this stuff
I really want to do this I want to give
it a shot I'm not worried about the
investment where my question actually is
is is there a safe way to pull together
money so that say there is a return
maybe it's not a hundred times whatever
if there's any return it's not all in
somebody's hands and we're just you know
well you want to get everything you know
contracts and writing I'd be working
with a lawyer to draft all of
this invest LLC yeah if you're truly not
worried about it and I believe you so if
you're not worried about the actual
money itself I'm going to put it into
this and ride it ride the wave right
then it's really the issue of you've got
some concerns you got some fears that
need to be addressed and the way you do
that is talk about it and get it all
work with professionals all the way
around no handshake agreements here but
I wish you the best man and obviously
you're doing with this with cash make
sure you're debt free with an emergency
fund before you start meddling with this
and that's fun
[Music]
money
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm
George camel joined by Ken Coleman if
you're a fan of the Ramsey Show be sure
to check out all of the shows on the
Ramsey Network including the Ken Coleman
show smart money happy hour that I
co-host with our friend Rachel Cruz uh
the George camel Channel on YouTube and
Spotify you can watch it over there as
well Dr John deloney show Rachel Cruz
show we got something for everyone Ken
entree leadership that's right by the
way there's a rumor that uh I may be
joining you and Rachel on Smart money
happy hour are you starting the rumor
right now well live you told me that you
would like to have me over there and how
fun it would be so maybe I'm start very
different sentence I would like to have
you I have no jurisdiction k I know you
do not I got no pull I get it so maybe
I've accidentally started it so I want
to go ahead and retract that because
you're my friend and I don't want to
well I'll be honest we had a special
guest on that will be the episode will
be released soon and it's Sharon Ramsay
see so she trumped you well of course
she should I don't know that there are
many people that uh are are more of a
favorite than Sharon Ramy for me she is
a great lady that'll be very fun it was
a fun episode highly Ed that'll be
coming to there was a lot of things that
didn't make cut we'll just put it that
way Ken just invite you and Rachel out
for drinks if you can get the queen on
the podcast or a court jester who are
you going to choose the Queen the queen
well put the court gesture will make the
cut I resemble that remark I can see it
yeah I like that that's just all I'm
looking for is excuse to have a beverage
with you we'd love to have you as soon
as Rachel allows it that's the one you
got to get through no well we'll get
there good luck with that but if you
like any of the shows including the Ramy
show please consider subscribing leaving
a review where you're listening sharing
it with a friend all of that that's our
marketing plan right there cat out of
the bag and we so appreciate all of you
who listen every week who send us
messages who post about it uh who leave
the reviews who subscribe it means the
world to us and it helps the algorithm
show it to more people so we can have
more impact out there thank you all
right Ken let's get back to the phones
Julia is waiting with baited breath in
Austin Texas Julia welcome to the
show hi thank you guys so much for
answering absolutely how can Ken and I
help
yeah um so I'm 25 my husband is 30 um I
have a past of managing finances
terribly or really just like not
managing finances at all um my husband
is a financial adviser thank God for
that one uh God really pulled through
for me on that um and he has really just
taken over everything when it comes to
managing our finances and money um and I
don't even look at our account and I
don't want to uh I just feel like it's
best for me to stay out of it given my
past do I need to be more
involved 100% yes you need to be more
involved because what's going to happen
inevitably is you are going to be
resentful at some point when you go what
I didn't know and he goes well I I mean
I managed the money you said you didn't
want anything to do with it and so you
need to have a vote even if you're not
the financially astute one where you go
I don't want to look at the spreadsheet
that's fine but you have to have a vote
you have to know what we're doing with
our money every sing month because
you're spending two
right yes so that tells me we're not on
a budget so we're not really managing
our money he's just handling the
In-N-Outs of the
account yeah and I do think that there
is a sense of anxiety that it causes him
that I could contribute to alleviating
if I did have these conversations with
him because he is it's something he's
passionate about too um so I don't know
if you have any advice on how to get
past my anxiety of like I don't like my
childhood was Mom and Dad hiding things
that they bought from each other when
they're walking in the door like our mom
would be like don't tell Dad about the
things in the back seat I'll come get
him in at 3 o'clock in the morning so I
just have this weird relationship with
uh finances and I went through uh FPU
and did that uh but it just feels better
to me that I don't even have to think
about it which might just be you know I
don't know not obviously not what best
but I don't know how to get over that
fear I can tell you how you actually
need to go get some counseling on that
very issue you have trauma over this
that's what this is this sounds very
normal to me for someone who has gone
through what you went through you would
just rather not you want to avoid it
completely because you feel like if I
avoid it then I can't be hurt by it and
I can't see my past come to fruition in
my own life that's what this is you
nailed it you diagnosed it beautifully
and I think honestly you just need to go
get with a great therapist and talk
through this stuff this is a this is a
wound that probably has not healed yet
well and you see money as this point of
contention instead of as a tool that can
help you guys live your best financial
life and that's going to that takes a
huge shift and one way to do that Julia
you tell me what is the opposite of
hiding it all and not talking about
it uh being open and having good
communication and having a good marriage
do you guys have that there it
is yeah forget about money do you guys
have an open Rel communication that like
the relationship is very open-minded
when we talk to each other and we were
able to talk about parenting or maybe
religion or whatever do you have that in
other
areas absolutely yeah well then you can
have it with money in fact you and this
is not an attack this is this is just
kind of an Embrace of what you've
already said you are the reason you
can't have the conversation about about
money if you can have it about other
things then this is just a fear and it's
a block and it's got It's got trauma
attached to it so you got to heal from
the trauma once you heal from the trauma
you'll be able to do what George is
talking about because you're doing it in
other
areas would you recommend I know you
guys recommended therapy would you
recommend us doing it together so
there's like an understanding or just
myself I think it'd be very helpful for
him to understand where you are coming
from because it's going to give him
tools that he can use to help you with
this yeah either one is great but for
him to sit in on the session and and
watch you do the hard work on this the
empathy he's going to have um and he's
probably going to start overc
communicating to make sure that you're
in the loop and that you have a vote and
that you have a say and part of that is
doing a monthly budget and doing maybe a
weekly budget meeting with him and I'm
going to gift you one year of every
dollar premium to help with that and
your here's your next goal is to go
we're going to make a budget and he
might help you create that but you're
going to have a vote and you're going to
have total visibility into what is our
family doing with money how much are we
spending on groceries how much do we
plan to spend how much do we actually
spend what are we putting into
Investments where is that being invested
can you explain that to me start being
really curious and asking good questions
and set some goals for yourself have a
self-care line item for Julia where she
gets to get her nails done every month
and everything's out there on the table
and that's going to help you see oh the
boogeyman is really not that scary I
just needed to put the flashlight under
the bed and take a look so the other
thing you can do is sign up we've got a
free webinar tomorrow with our friend
Jade warshaw Wednesday November 29th
12:30 Eastern Time 11:30 central time
it's about an hour long and she's going
to walk you through how to set up your
very first every dollar budget how to
break this paycheck to paycheck cycle so
many people find themselves in and I
think it's going to give you some
confidence in what it looks like to pay
attention to money and not be afraid of
it awesome that's great thank you I one
last question um what do you guys
recommend what kind of therapist would I
speak out would would I just type in
like is there such thing as a financial
therapist or would it just be like
family counseling to get past it there
there's Financial coaching but I think
what Ken is saying is you need a
traditional counselor traditional
therapist our friends at betterhelp are
a great start you can do this remotely
online sit with him at home in the
living room and do this so that's a
great start and then if you want to
pursue someone locally you can also do
that okay awesome thank you guys so much
absolutely Julia we're rooting for you
yeah you're gonna do great she's gonna
win 100% the fact that she's self-aware
and wanting to grow in this area and
going I feel like I should and here's
the root issue and I'm willing to deal
with it that's everything well I mean
she told us pretty much the source of
the trauma yeah and I think a great
therapist is going to be able to go you
know let's dig into that and figure that
out and and uh I love the fact that
they've already got a great marriage
where they're talking about everything
else and once she gets over over that
that pain you know I think he's going to
be excited that she wants to talk about
M sounds like he's very passionate about
it oh yeah he does it for a living he's
going you want to talk about budgeting
absolutely let's go right so uh I didn't
give you the website the website to go
to to sign up for that free webinar with
our friend Jade warshaw is
everydollar.com budgeting it's
completely free it's Wednesday November
29th 12:30 p.m. eastern time 11:30
central time over the lunch break there
and it's going to be super helpful to
visually see every dollar see how it can
create margin to help you accomplish all
of your goals whether your paycheck to
paycheck or whether you're baby step 7
uh it's all there including some of the
awesome premium features our team has
been working on so go check that out
everydollar.com budgeting it's one of
the best ways to curb anxiety with money
CU just paying attention to it gives you
a sense of confidence and control that
nothing else can do this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
this is the Ramsay show our scripture of
the day James
1:12 blessed is the one who perseveres
under trial because having stood the
test that person will receive the crown
of life that the Lord has promised to
those who love him Claude pepper said
life is like riding a bicycle you don't
fall off unless you stop pedaling Claude
there we go do we know who Claude pepper
is I had no idea probably someone very
famous and roast in the comments in a
while well see I don't want to eat up
any time but I'm going to look up Claude
really fast I wish President Biden had
read that cuz that must have been what
happened when he fell off that bike must
have stopped pedaling nice That's a
classic that's why bik Claude pepper was
a uh American politician of the
democratic party there you go that
tracks and I guess he was a congressman
from 1963 so anyway thank you Claude
there we go they pulled up the Wikipedia
for us Ken what if my name was Claude
Coleman uh I'd buy it you look like a
Claude and I don't mean that I don't
mean that in a kind way that I didn't
take it that way but you let's see folks
I just wanted to say something this is
why I love George Campbell I give him an
opportunity like that and he doesn't
miss itall that's t-ball and I liked it
it was right that was a shot to the ribs
and I liked it cuz we're friends we are
friends that's funny but I think Claude
Coleman's funny it's a lot funnier
sounding than Ken Coleman but I digress
Let's Help Alexandra out that's a much
better name Alexandra in San Jose it's a
much better name Alexandra how can we
help
today hi I'm so glad to talk to you you
guys are my favorite Duo on the ramd
show what Alexandre you're our favorite
caller love you guys so much GE you're
so funny and Ken you always give the
best
advice thank you so my question today is
I recently got a second job and it is to
help me basically save up for my moov to
Idaho and I met my boss at least a week
ago over the weekend and she hasn't seem
like she's really the nicest person
she's very rude um when I first met her
we went um to do some training and she
got upset that I had brought a pack to
lunch with me to work um and then
yesterday she called me and because I've
been asking so many questions because I
new to the place um and I haven't really
gotten the proper training that I've
been asking questions and she called me
Annoying for asking her questions
regarding my job and I just don't really
know how to handle a person like that
who is angry all the time yeah and how
long you've been in this
job it's been two weeks o and you're
thinking about moving to Idaho for this
I'm thinking about move yeah I've been
planning to move to Idaho since the
spring earlier this year okay um just
because in californ
it's getting out of control the
connection so here's here's why I'm
asking here's why I'm asking the Idaho
question so you want to move to Idaho
whether this job is is this a remote job
anyway um no it is in person so you've
already made the move to
Idaho I have not so this is in the San
Jose area I'm so confused okay okay so
so I'm planning to move to Idaho and I
got this job so that I can save up money
oh I see so this is your second job and
you have the rude boss at the second
job yes oh okay so this is temporary all
right I'm trying to get to the bottom of
because here here's why I'm asking all
the questions
okay this isn't worth putting up with
she's not going to change this is a
woman who got upset with you because you
brought a packed lunch how dare you who
gets irritated over somebody packing
their
lunch yeah she seems like the type of
person who gets very triggered by people
who just live a different lifestyle than
she does uh yes and and this is America
you know you can you know you have
absolutely right I didn't know person
lunch was a lifestyle it's not she's
just unhappy and she's looking for
anything possible to be rude about cuz
she's very
unhappy can I ask what kind of job this
is this is a sales job it's a um it's a
company based in South Korea where um
it's a wellness company that sells um
thermal massage beds
um that look like furniture and so we
are we cater mostly to people who have
back problems or for people who work all
all day lift how do things um it sounds
delightful I would love this product
problems I would love this product but
this is just a second job for you so how
much are you making in this second job
is it hourly or is it
commission it's both so I make
40K is my yearly income and then on top
of that I Mak 300 per unit I sell okay
$300 per unit I sell I think you have
two options one you just put up with her
nonsense you know and just put up with
it because it's a second job and it's a
means to an end it's literally I'm
trying to bank money so that I can check
out of California and move to Idaho so
you either just decide can I put up with
her rudeness and move on and make good
money and just deal with her whatever
she is or the other option is to go if I
can't deal with it then I got to move on
and I'll go find me another second job
that I can make the same amount of money
and not deal with all her crap those are
your two options she's not going to
change yeah and I realize that so which
is the bigger hassle thing is that she
basically so my my main income I work
for my mother she's an abstract um
artist and she has her own business and
so I handle like all of her social media
um and I also assist her at some of her
workshops too that she does Across the
Nation
okay and that's $2 an hour um and it can
be it's it's part-time and then the
other one
is it is also part-time um so I work
five days a week for my mom and I
usually work early in the morning and
then um I basically work at my other job
from 10:30 a.m. to
700 p.m. so it's about an 8 and a half
hour shift but that's irrelevant depends
on how much they schedu it's irrelevant
the question is which is the bigger
nuisance for you dealing with the rude
boss who's clearly hurting and she her
life sucks in some
way uh or moving on to uh a different
part-time job which is the bigger
nuisance or you just say I'm not going
to work for Mom I'm not going to work
for a rude person and I'm going to go
get a full-time job that pays me really
well so can stack up cash and move to
Idaho you have three options which is
the
least of a
nuisance because these are all
short-term
plays yeah so which
one well I definitely want to um work in
customer service as a full-time job and
I've been applying to places like that
um and for some reason I'm not getting
any well that's okay you just got to
stay with it but I mean here's what I
want to do I want to answer your
question why you
called and and so you're not going to
change this lady you're not going to
change
her so yeah you you have the option to
deal with it and keep stacking the cash
that comes with it and go this is just a
short-term play or you move on to
another short-term play you have to
decide but you don't have to leave you
could put up with her long enough to
replace that job work around her mhm no
I'm asking can you
yeah I mean I think I want to stay with
the company just because it is still new
and I
do income to keep then who cares what
she says about your pack lunch and who
cares if she calls you annoying you know
get the answers you need to do the job
well yeah well I the thing is is that I
never really have to see her in person
she just calls me because she lives in
Los Angeles great even better she's the
regional she's the regional manager and
I'm the supervisor of the store
great um so I report to her on the basis
of you know the day that I well she
can't see any more of your pack lunches
so that problem is solved that's true
there we go one problem solved I would
just put your head down and do your job
and don't worry about her but sorry
going through that that's never fun and
uh hopefully it gives you more fuel to
make this move to Idaho and and follow
your dream and get a great customer
service job and all of
that yeah I hope so and Alexander I want
you to I want you to hang on the line
and listen to this I'm going to put
George in a in roleplay situation I
think this is perfect okay hit me cuz
she thinks you're very funny so it put
you on the spot You're In Her Shoes
you're just asking basic questions cuz
you haven't been trained properly yep
and and the boss says you're so annoying
George what do you say you sound just
like my
mother that's it you try to diffuse it
you know see if you get a laugh out of
them if not you go well 0 for one well
we'll have another at bat Sports
reference boom nailed it wow folks that
puts this hour of the ramsy show and the
books my thanks to the legendary Ken
Coleman all the guys in the booth
keeping the show float today and you
America we do this show for you and it's
because of you we appreciate it we'll be
back with you before you know
[Music]
it
n